President Trump and Nancy Pelosi
engaging in some heated personal attacks
trading shots all weekend the speaker
blasting Trump's response to the
outbreak the president has made many
mistakes leaders take responsibility so
I said he's a weak leader he doesn't
take responsibility
he places blames blame on others and
that might have been okay for before but
we cannot continue down a path that is
again I'll come back to science science
science evidence data on how we could go
forward Trump and Pelosi also clashing
over a new round of funding to help
struggling small businesses Republicans
lashing out at Democrats over delays
because funding for the program ran out
last week after an impasse it does look
like the White House and Congress are
close on a four hundred and seventy
billion dollar package to help small
business owners president Trump weighed
in on that you say it's ready to go then
they say we have a good negotiating
position now because he just said it's
ready to go we're negotiating with the
Democrats and you know they negotiate
for things that we can't do that we
don't think are in the best interest of
the people of this country we are very
close to a deal Dagan let me go to you
first on this because I wanted to point
out that it is likely that whatever they
pass is going to look almost identical
to what they had proposed two weeks ago
so this money didn't actually have to
run out it was they were just playing
politics with it and now you have small
business owners who have applied and
they can't get their money and every day
they're thinking they're going to have
to lay off or they're going lay off
people or they're going to have to lose
their business these are people these
are family businesses that are flat on
their backs and these people don't know
how they're going to stay open because
the Democrats were playing politics with
a reload and a refresh and a refill of
this small business paycheck protection
program seven days before that program
ran out of money Mitch McConnell put in
front of the Democrats a 25 line bill
just for the money and what did they do
they dragged their feet so every time
any one of these Democrats ever says
small businesses and they're going to
tell you how important they are to the
fabric of America
those two words should be preceded with
go-to-hell
small businesses because that's what you
did and now they're trying to turn it on
the Republicans the Democrats are
talking about why did the blue states
not get as many loans filled as some of
the red states did you know why because
that's where the big banks were and they
deserve a lot of the blame as well
because Wells Fargo made what a hunt
about a hundred and twenty million
dollars in loans out of a three hundred
fifty billion dollar program those big
banks Bank of America JP Morgan they
slowed off these loans for the first ten
days of the program when they should
have been stepping up like the community
banks they're ashamed to go around and
I've got a steaming pile of horse manure
where they can all jump in there I
wanted to go to you first on that Greg
what about this feud between Pelosi and
Trump we're going through a major
emergency a pandemic in an election year
of very high stakes well you know Dana I
hate it when politics you know intrudes
in such issues
but first I want to first I want to
address the small business owners that
are being ignored there's a lot of sole
proprietors and 1099 non salaried
workers that are being turned down by
banks as well so restaurants and
hospitality entertainment sectors they
employ a lot of non salaried workers and
they're not getting they're not getting
any help from the banks on that cuz we
don't accept 1099 that also needs to be
addressed okay to the to the feud we
learned in times of virus that politics
is incurable
and it's in its chief symptom is amnesia
in which it allows people to accuse
others of sins that they just committed
like Pelosi or de Blasio or a Cuomo who
all told people doctor changed their
lives or to you know just keep going to
mass events so they really can't
criticize Trump especially about delay
since they're telling people it was no
big deal
I mean wasn't Pelosi focusing on the
exaggerated hysteria of flavor
vapes before she got around to this by
the way everybody do themselves a favor
google dan Crenshaw on Bill Maher it's
the best
yeah yep you should do that it has spent
some time with that one Jesse the other
thing that's happening is to some of
these small business owners like
restaurants they have their rents that
they have to pay to their landlords and
they're not sure if they're gonna be
able to make it much longer
yeah could you imagine Dan if there was
a Republican in charge and that
Republican was holding up money to small
businesses to families in the middle of
an economic calamity the media would be
breathing fire
but for some reason Nancy Pelosi gets a
pass I can't believe she says Trump
bungled this thing that must mean foul
Chee and Burkes bungled it because every
time foul Chee and Burkes came to the
president with a recommendation on
travel bans or mitigation he acted
immediately on it I mean it was March
16th that they said shut this down Trump
shuts it down yummie deaths there were
in America and March 16th five dozen if
Nancy knew on March 16th that we should
have shut it down two weeks earlier why
didn't she get on the horn with Falchi
and Burks and say hey guys you're two
weeks late because on March 1st there
was one death and if Nostradamus Nancy
knew after one death in the United
States on March 1st we need to shut the
greatest economy in the world down well
then my god she's in the wrong line of
business because no one knew at that
point the Europeans hadn't shut anything
down
no one knew a thing and I had our
researchers check to see if Nancy Pelosi
had pointed a finger at China or at the
WHL guess how many instances they found
zero that says a lot about Nancy and
we're gonna talk about she's colluding
with the Chinese maybe we should
wiretapper well let me get one in here
we're gonna talk about the Chinese and
the Democrats Republicans in the next
block with one one do you think that
Congress should consider responsibly
coming back to Washington to try to work
these things out in a quicker way
sure and I think that speaker makan I'm
sorry majority leader McConnell has said
you know we need to get this done and he
says he's going to open the Senate I
think four o'clock tomorrow Dana defer a
vote but they couldn't get everything
done in place today
so yeah they need to get it done but to
your point and so the other points
listen I think Democrats here are
advocating that the money needs to go to
regular folks to the people the American
people and not through the JP Morgan's
and not end up in the hands of Ruth's
Chris Steakhouse because even though
it's a big company individual franchises
apply and then they get all the money or
Shake Shack get so much money and then
finally says hey this backlash coming at
us we got to give some of the money give
I think they gave all the money back
because they were getting hit so hard
with the point is that you want yeah so
you what you need is you need smaller
banks and I think that's part of what
Schumer and the Democrats want you need
smaller banks that do community banking
that reach out to small businesses and
localities both urban and rural and too
small or even nonprofit organizations to
make sure they get a fair share of this
money and it doesn't simply go to people
who are politically connected at the
very top not only in terms of Washington
but in terms of the big banks that's not
fear and I think people
train whistle means it's a good point